what I want to do is uh perform for you
what I hope will feel a bit like a quote
unquote traditional magic trick you're
going to see in a second why I put those
quote marks there um you should never
trust someone by the way who comes to
you with a deck of cards I'm taking off
my watch so you know there's nothing up
my sleeves which I already rolled up uh
have a look at my deck of cards by the
way you can see it's a deck just like
yours there are such a thing as um trick
decks like they're all the same card or
if you have a look at the back as I
shuffle them there's a pattern under
that who's got this deck of cards by the
way because there's many sets of these
who's got the yeah at the back so you've
got the same design right
um to the rest of us as you're looking
at them quickly all those back designs
look the same don't they but some
magicians have a deck that's set up so
that there's very subtle differences
between one card and the next so they're
like oh I actually know that this is the
eight of diamonds because I've memorized
the pattern right but hopefully you're
satisfied that this is a normal deck are
you okay with that yeah okay fantastic
now
for this next part of the trick I
actually need
um I need a volunteer actually now maybe
I'll do it this way I just realized
because I'm in case you haven't worked
out I'm filming this and I don't want to
necessarily I haven't gotten like uh
what's it called authority to publish
that that type of thing right I haven't
done that for anyone so I'm going to
actually do this a little differently
um what's your name here in the front
Mario Arya okay Aria you're gonna help
me in a second but just before we do
that I'm actually going to try and use
all of you um to do this next part
usually I would have someone sit where
I'm sitting and I'll give them
instructions and they would select a
card but we're going to use all of you
together to help me out okay so Arya
just take this deck of cards here could
you just as I talked through all of this
with the class just gently shuffle them
no hurry or anything like that just make
sure they're very mixed up okay
um who shall I ask uh it's David isn't
it David you were first in a class so
I'm going to reward you
um by having the final decision okay so
we're going to come back to you in a
moment
um let's see who can I ask next can I
get a volunteer
okay yeah what's your name
can you pick we've got three rows here
of cards right first uh or around the
top middle bottom which row would you
like
middle middle okay so I'm gonna get rid
of all of these cards here okay
and um David right uh David of these
three cards uh left middle right which
one would you like
left okay so this is your card right
here okay now what I'm going to do this
part's tricky because
um you're gonna I'm gonna need to
persuade you that I'm not about to see
what's happening okay so to do that what
I'm going to do is first I'm going to
take off my glasses right so I'm
suitably blind okay I'm also going to
put my hand on the card so that I know
which one it is and I'm going to cover
my my eyes which already closed I'm
going to cover my eyes so I'm not
looking okay are you satisfied like some
of you if you like just watch me don't
bother watching the screen just so you
can convince yourself that I'm not
watching okay I lost where the card is
it's that one right yeah okay good all
right what I'm going to do is I'm going
to turn this card over and I'm doing
that so that you can memorize what card
it is okay now I'm gonna do that right
now
I don't know if I can pick it up all
right here we go now I don't know what
card it is hopefully you can all see it
actually can you give me an indication
can you see it yeah okay
um don't say it aloud obviously but have
you memorized it yet you're happy to
remember it you must memorize because
this trick is much less impressive if I
get to the end of this trick and then
I'm like is this your card and you can't
remember okay so your content now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to take
this card here it is right here I'm
going to turn it back over and then
where's my Pilots here right okay I
haven't looked at the card it's just
gone on the top there are you satisfied
that I've kept my eyes hidden this whole
time yep okay are you do you mind is it
invisible now can I open my eyes again
yeah okay fantastic all right um Arya do
you feel like those cards are well
shuffled okay fantastic thank you very
much now what I'm going to do at this
point is
uh is the part of the trick that you're
going to perform as well okay now this
is the part that hopefully feels a bit
like magic I'm going to try and do uh
one better than what a magician would do
which is like they would go through the
cards they would look at them and then
say is this your card okay
um I'm not a magician I am a
mathematician so I'm going to try and do
better than me working out what your
card is I'm going to try and get the
deck of cards itself to tell me
which card was the one that you chose
together right here's the way I'm going
to do it I'm going to deal these cards
out on the table as I deal I'm going to
count down like a like a rocket blast
off you know ten nine eight and so on
okay
as I count down
if the number I say aloud is the same as
the number of the card I put on the
table
that is the deck of cards communicating
with him with me and telling me to stop
okay it's a bit easier to understand if
I actually just do it right so I'm going
to count down now I'm going to say 10
. now I would have said nine next except
um I don't know how many of you guys
play with cards at all like it's a bit
old-fashioned yeah a few of you okay
some of you know in most card games the
court cards are the Jack the queen and
the King they often have a value of 10
not in every game but in a lot of games
okay so I said 10 the deck of cards also
said 10 so that means stop okay I've
done this once and introduced four times
okay so I'm gonna go 10
nine
eight
okay did you see what just happened I
said eight deck of cards at eight that
means stop okay you get the idea now I'm
gonna speed up a little bit because I
think you understand
um I said I was gonna do it four times
so two down two to go ten nine eight
seven
okay seven last one
ten
okay Jack queen king they're all ten I
need your help one last time
ten plus eight plus seven plus ten
what's that equal to
35
are you sure
yeah okay I love how some of you like
yeah no I'm not sure no it definitely is
35. okay let's see if you're correct one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen Seventeen eighteen
nineteen twenty Twenty One 22 23 24 25
26 27 28 29
30 31 32 33 34 35
was this your card
okay
so
remember I said to you before right that
you are going to be doing four stages
today you just learned the trick I just
performed in front of you you're about
to do it too I know probably some of you
have forgotten what was the first thing
I did at the beginning that's fine I'll
rehearse it for you but the key thing is
you're going to perform this with the
goal of understanding what just happened
maybe some of you already think you have
a clue like I think a good idea of how
some of it worked maybe not all of it
okay so between the two of you I want
you to choose who's going to perform the
trick first this is a one person trick
so one person performs it the other
person gets it done to them okay
um we'll get you into a group shortly
okay maybe you want to just as a three
do you want to just join the group in
front of you for a second there we go
okay
so hands up who's doing the trick hands
up who's doing the trick okay good I
need to know who I'm making eye contact
with over here okay fantastic all right
so let me review for you hands down for
the person performing the trip you need
to know a few things okay so let me just
put this all back
um person performing you need the deck
of cards in front of you are they all
shuffled by the way they're all mixed up
yep okay now the first thing I want you
to remember is I gave you garmia David
you helped me out with this I gave you a
genuine Choice as to what card you chose
but I didn't give you all the cards to
choose from remember that actually Arya
had most of the cards he was shuffling
them does anyone remember how many cards
could you choose from it was nine three
times three right so the first thing I'd
like you to do is person performing a
trick could you please give three six
nine cards to the person you're doing
the trick two you can go ahead and do
that all right okay
so now we switch over to the other
person
who's getting the treat done to them
you've got nine cards now okay now what
you want to do is you've got to pick the
card and obviously perform up please
look away a virtualize close your eyes
whatever you need to do
um once you pick your card right do you
remember suppose you pick this card
right do you remember what did we do
with that card I had to do this with my
eyes closed once you pick the card you
I actually asked you to memorize it yes
and then I left it in a particular spot
it was right
on the top do you remember that okay so
person who's got the nine cards in your
hand just wait there for a minute
person with the nine cards in your hand
have you memorized your card yet yes you
got it okay leave it on top okay goes on
the table
all right performer one last part of the
puzzle here
you are going to take the rest of the
cards
and pop them right on the top okay now
before I let you go uh there is one last
thing that actually didn't happen when I
performed the trick because when I
perform this trick it's different every
single time right and you're about to
experience this different every time
right there's one thing that didn't
happen and I just want you to see what
happens in case right suppose you're
counting down ten nine eight just
suppose that wasn't an eight okay just
let's just suppose uh seven six five
four three just suppose it's not a three
okay two one sometimes your your number
never matches the cards that you're
putting on the table and that's fine
what's the last number in a countdown
zero if you never match your card never
matches the number you say allowed put a
card on top that's blank and that's the
the zero because there is actually no
zero card in the day in the deck does
that make sense good luck have a go and
see if it works off you go